for the third year in a row ladies and
gentlemen we're taking our show down to
San Diego for comic-con
we're gonna be airing a week of shows
live from the Spreckels theater in San
Diego we got lots of exciting stuff
planned including a ton of surprise
guests
we'll be announcing that soon it's all
happening Wednesday July 19th through
Sunday July 23rd not our normal nines
but for Comic Con it's so exciting
right we change we changed the time yeah
we change the whole time man change this
is very high right now anyway very very
yeah I like you staying on my shot and
Auntie leaning in to explain how high
here really so happening July 19th
through July 23rd that is the Wednesday
through Sunday check it out for more
info visit team koco.com
slash comic-con
to help us to help us get in the mood
for Comicon because you got to get in
the comic-con mood
we'd like to once again bring out
Captain Kirk's arch-nemesis that's right
he's a genetically enhanced super being
who wants to conquer the earth
he's also people don't know this a
hard-working club comic
please welcome Kirk's number-one enemy
Comic Con yes thank you great crowd
great to be here I know what you're
thinking Khan has really put on some
weight yes I accidentally set my phaser
to carbs I've really packed on the
pounds it turns out that revenge is a
dish best served with a side of
crinkle-cut fries
[Music]
what else what else oh here's one what
you call Captain Kirk and a barn full of
animals you call the police because that
dude is definitely going to try to burn
those animals that guy will have sex
with anything I tell you
yes Kirk's a freak curse mission was to
go where no man had gone before you know
where else he's never gone before the
shower the shower curse Mel's he knows
what I'm saying yes okay one more joke
you've been great one more time a horse
walks into a bar and the bartender says
look out Captain Kirk is behind you and
he's definitely going to try to bone you
yes that guy will squirrel anything
[Applause]
you've been great I've been calm well
you can see you can see you can see
Comic Con this weekend at the laughs
farm in Pacoima and after that he'll be
decimating the alien population of
Planet ontari sevens yes I'll be killing
in both places thank you very much
[Applause]
you